I must say I've come to it very much as
a human rights issue because when I've
been in African countries doing my
current work on health,
on decent work,
on women's leadership,
people would sort of change the subjects
they but what can we do?
We've no seasons anymore and our farming
is destroyed.
Farmers don't have winter,
so it's undermining everything and then
I realized that in fact the reality is
that our carbon based lifestyles
creating these greenhouse gas emissions
are already affecting the poorest and in
a way I think that's not the way we hear
about climate change.
We hear it from scientists and
environmentalist and economists and they
have important things to say,
but they're talking statistics and a
polar bear on a melting ice floe and
glaciers melting people's earlier
started going to be a problem in the
future for many,
many poor people.
It's a problem now and it's undermining
their poor life chances and it could
lead to conflict.
When you have water stress,
when you have people migrating,
they estimate that by 2050 we could have
more than $200,
million environmental climate change.
Migrants who've had to move either
within the countries are very often
across borders.
Many of them will want to come to
Europe.
They want to come from,
you know,
South America more to the United States
if they find arid conditions where they
can't continue to where they live,
other flooded,
and these are unfortunately the threats.
So we need,
again,
a developmental approach.
We need,
in fact,
to ensure that we mitigate our own
carbon.
We can all do more about that,
including me.
I travel on airplanes a lot.
I'm trying to think how to video more
and to be able to be more energy
efficient in our home,
et cetera.
But,
uh,
also we need to help countries that are
in poor parts of the world where they
suffer much more from any slight change
in climbers.
They have no insurance and they're
devastated.
Look at what's happening in Pakistan at
the moment.